Welcome to Eden. Okay?
The ultimate playground for couples.
It's got fun, it's got sun.
It's Disneyland for adults.
Wow. That is amazing.
Yeah, you guys are gonna have a blast.
Actually, we have found a great group rate.
Oh, there's the fine print.
No, no. Now, Joey, you know, just...
The embarrassing fact is that,...
...Cynthia and I can't afford to go to this place by ourselves,...
...but if all of us go together, it's half-price.
It's called the Pelican Package. Okay?
It's six nights, seven days and it's all-inclusive.
And there are quite a few activities you can choose from.
Who here likes to eat?
I know you guys do.
I sure do.
Right?
Boom!
Why not do it at a four-star restaurant?
You guys, it has a state-of-the-art spa.
They've got your kayaking, they've got your windsurfing.
They've got your canoeing, they've got your jet skiing.
It's got Couples Skill Building.
That's the great thing about the Pelican Package, you guys.
It really includes everything.
Obviously, Jason and I want to partake in the Couples Skill Building,...
...but you guys can just do the fun stuff.
So, what are we asking?
We're asking for you guys to fly to paradise and have an awesome time, okay?
I mean, this, come on, it would be a blast.